[Musique]
des bisous pour dire bonjour pour dire
au revoir bisous politique symbolique
mais aussi bisou de star et surtout
bisous mythique mais aujourd'hui tout ça
c'est interdit salué sans serrer la main
et lui éviter les embrassades vite et
les embrassades vie que les embrasse un
sombre et la bise interdite
compliqué en france où elle a une
certaine importance
d'ailleurs la télévision lui a consacré
des sujets entier exemple en 1979
partons à la découverte du baiser pour
françois truffaut la bise le baiser
c'était sacré le summum du couple sur un
grand écran
mais à la fin des années 70 le
réalisateur regretter qu'il perde de sa
superbe
le baiser perd de son importance il perd
de sa valeur événementiel c'est ça c'est
ce que je voulais dire le baiser devrait
être un événement un événement certes
mais qu'il faut pouvoir partager la
personne
la bise à ses propres codes par région
de 3,4 bisous par la joue gauche par la
joue droite
bref une culture du bisou à la française
défendue jusqu'à l'assemblée nationale
par jean lassalle en 2007
c'est comme kolo serre la vis c'est
formidable ça ça donne ça déclenche de
samedi 20 comprenez une coutume déjà
menacé en 2009 lors de la grippe a
lorsque la maire du guilvinec vous
l'êtes interdire la bise à ses
administrés ça faisait marrer jean
pierre pernaut elle souhaite qu'on
remplace le biseau par une sorte de
salut à l'indienne pub pour les pêcheurs
du finistère c'était hors de question
tous les ans ça changera pas le problème
si on veut dire bonjour jai avant le
bisou voilà fini terminé
comment qui vont faire les 10 jeunes qui
flirte c'est fini alors ils vont pouvoir
bragg est rude et plus de contacts plus
de bisous à la place des gestes
barrières et de la distanciation sociale
mais les archives de la télévision elles
peuvent encore nous mes côtés
excusez moi je vous en prie
[Musique]